what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on so pumped to
be talking about Miss information
security we have dr. David pearl men
joining on the son on the show hi David
hi Alan thanks for having me I'm so
pumped for this conversation thanks for
coming on the program I'm pretty pumped
too I love it it was so cool meeting you
and getting to know you more last year
and now getting the chance to sit down
with you and talk about this very very
pressing field that's emerging for those
who don't know David's background he's
founder and CEO of cogs tech
technologies cognitive security
technologies the first misinformation
security vendor protecting socio
technical systems of enterprises and you
can find the link in the bio below to
Cox tech dot tech as well as his
LinkedIn and the Twitter profile for the
company David we're so obsessed with
this question and we start all of our
shows at this moment very pumped ask you
it what do you think is the point of
this creation the point of this creation
Wow that is that is a big question and
you know I'm gonna buy some time by
giving a shout-out to my co-founders at
the company and just thanks to all the
people who supported me Sarah Jane turf
is the chief science officer and she
actually invented the term
misinformation security as far as I know
and you know another friend ran
Boltzmann invented cog sack cognitive
security technologies so I owe so much
to so many people and I don't have time
to thank everyone but I just you know
it's really important to me to show
gratitude and I want to start with that
it's beautiful and hopefully we can
feature some of the yeah minds that you
get to collaborate with and that have
been such major influences on you yeah
you'll you'll be hearing from us so what
is the point of all this why are we here
you know there's there's a few different
ways I could answer that question one of
them would be like the physicist type
answer of like oh you know
big bang in the equations and
Schrodinger's equation and stuff like
that and one of them would be sort of
assuming that maybe God created the
universe and then asking the question
why what was the intended like the
preordained intended purpose but the
version of the question that I
personally feel the most connection to
is what do you experience as your
purpose in existing mm-hmm and one of
the reasons I like that question is
because it's yeah it's a lot harder to
get into the kind of argument that
starts wars over that question because
it's really very individual you know I
think everyone you you can't really stop
people from choosing their own beliefs
about what the purpose of their
existence is I do think that there are
some that tend to work out better than
others and there's some that I think are
really valuable kindness compassion
self-knowledge both at an individual
level and at a collective level you know
building a kinder world just between you
and your friends is one thing you and
your family you and your children you
and your partners building a kinder
world for all of us to live in is a
similar sort of work but it takes a
different set of skills you and I have
talked about meditation in the past and
how that fits into all this I don't know
maybe we'll get back around to that
later but I think that if I had to say
one thing that I've chosen as a purpose
I think it's to do work at a collective
level that helps as many people as
possible reduce their suffering and or
live a more positive and satisfying
existence yeah yeah it's beautiful thank
you for that yeah that's so good
and this also stems for your from your
initial
pursuits into neuroscience and
psychology and doing your PhD and the
Center for healthy minds which we will
talk about and also up until even today
let's jump let's jump into this I like
that that perspective about
understanding what is your individual
divine purpose here and figuring that
out is of paramount importance of know
thyself
and also figuring out why we are here
together what uh what is the highest
possibility that we're all working on
bringing forth I did kind of punt that
question you did okay let's let's go in
to as we are experiencing this big
collective emergence of information
technology these computers and this
internet have absolutely revolutionized
our world in a myriad of ways one of
them being our ability to disseminate
information at such fast speeds and to
so many people and now the question is
are we doing this for inclusive fitness
do i am i doing am i disseminating ameen
because i I love you and I care for you
and I want to share beautiful important
knowledge with you or my disseminating
things that are self-dealing
that I just want to earn money from you
or that I just want to cause some sort
of malevolence on you to disrupt a
democratic process or whatever it may be
so I'm really glad that this is where
you've like your just right here right
now so tell us about your big-picture
view on what's what's going on well you
want to hear my big-picture view on the
good parts or on the bad parts give us
both well like like you said I don't
know if this is good or just neutral but
like you said I think it's we're
obviously
kind of maybe what you might call an
inflection point in terms of information
technology there's you know I could me
and my partner's all have a whole
lecture that we do about the history of
information technologies and the
invention of the printing press and the
democratization of information
distribution I think one of the key
points to understand is that there
there's sort of two things that are
happening at the same time right now and
one of them is that everyone has access
to a nearly universal broadcast medium
and this was never true before people
had access to information from all over
with the fact that you could shout out
into the void and maybe everyone would
hear it that's new because of social
media and then the other thing that has
come together for not entirely equally
obvious reasons that I won't go into
having to do with economics of the
internet and stuff like that the
traditional news media is kind of
breaking down so we're left with a not
so much an information vacuum but we're
left with a credibility vacuum where
there's not as much resources available
for someone to do really really careful
analysis and then there's also still the
sense that somebody should be
trustworthy so what that means is that
you know maybe in the future no one will
believe anything they read and maybe a
different set of problems will come from
that but the problem is that right now
everybody has the sense that someone out
there is a credible source but there
isn't really anything determining who it
is so basically whoever manages to play
the game right can actually convince
everyone that they are a credible source
and then people really believe what they
have to say
so you ask the question you know why are
you sending this meme out what's in your
heart when you send the meme out and I
think it's important for people
individually to think about that you
know and maybe there's some some kind of
skills that people could learn about
filtering information but I was talking
earlier about the individual and the
collective and for me what's more
important is to think about how do we
build the systems so that the outcomes
generate less suffering
mm-hmm so the systems would be things
like democratic societies as opposed to
authoritarian regimes and then there's
an information ecosystem that has to go
with that and then unavoidably the
information ecosystem is digital and
democracy depends on a mass information
ecosystem so then it basically boils
down to what is the nature of the
digital information infrastructure of a
society as one of the key points for
whether you have a society that
generates suffering more or less
suffering or people have satisfactory
lives within that society I'm gonna put
it back to you where would you like me
to go next on that topic
Wow so many profound insights there
exactly yeah so let's let's start with
first is this the view on the big
picture is that now there's this almost
Universal broadcast medium that we have
this tool that we can now propagate
memes out with and then then there's the
credibility vacuum like you listed and I
like that that terminology way more
distrust happening now for the
mainstream media new sources way more
distrust happening for our even our
Congress and in many ways the founding
principles were not to have one person
representing hundreds of thousands of
people but rather one person
representing thousands of people I
believe the figures are we were supposed
to have at this rate of increase of
population up closer to 8,000 people in
in Congress and so it's it's it's a very
this is becoming more and more of a
pressing issue to figure out like you
said in this last point about democracy
about the nature of the way that the
information is communicated between
humans is then the way that we decide on
how we best want to live collectively
okay so
maybe one of the next areas that we
should go with this is that you know
you're starting cognitive security
technologies you guys I love I love this
about you guys you're doing this quote
this quote about you is really good
early detection and attribution of
disinformation campaigns I love that so
maybe give us a little bit of insight on
the background of disinformation
campaigns this can actually you also
were teaching us about this before we
started that now you can hack mass
psychology mm-hmm
so we work a lot with the idea of socio
technical systems where you're you're
drawing a box around the system and the
box includes people inside it and
machines networks so in order to
understand the workings of a socio
technical system as a system you have to
take into account individual
psychological factors collective
psychological sociological factors and
also the behavior of the computer
networks so it's that sort of collective
expertise that our team is good at at
bringing all these pieces together so
when you talk about socio technical
systems what I was saying before about
in order to have a society you have an
information ecosystem the information
ecosystem is a socio technical system
because it consists of all these people
who are in continual interaction with
digital channels but then they also talk
to each other person to person you know
they call their friend on a phone which
is a digital connection and then they
say something to them which is a
psychological phenomenon so from the
point of view of us develop
misinformation security so what what
what I mean by that is if you ask this
question how do you build or what would
be the specifications for an information
ecosystem that leads to
positive and benevolent society there's
sort of two questions and this is a
parallels an age-old question there you
have wartime and peacetime traditionally
so basically you have the question of
when everything's going well what works
well and then you have when everything
is going to hell what works well hmm so
when people talk about the attention
economy and the extractive economy and
you know they like too much distraction
information overload they're sort of
talking about what you might call the
peacetime questions about building the
information foundations of our society
and well we're only recently seeing
people start to talk about is what you
might call and I'm you know deliberately
being provocative here but what you
might call the wartime foundations of
the information infrastructure of a
Democratic Society yeah and what that
means is what happens when it comes
under attack and what attack means is
that someone with a fixed set someone
with goals which are not in our best
interest is using our information
ecosystem to hurt us
you know whether to add any number of
things you know I mean the most obvious
thing if you want to just go with the
parallel of going with a traditional
military parallel somebody you have a
hostile foreign power and they're
thinking well we could invade and you
know shoot guns and bullets and bombs
and stuff and then we like you know take
over and we seize the capital and then
we have annexed this country like we saw
with the with Russia and the Ukraine in
2014 like you just roll the tanks in and
you take over the capital and then you
have annexed this country with the what
you want but like the the attackers goal
is to control that country and a smart
attacker will be thinking what are the
various ways that I could control that
country so when I say the war time basis
of the information infrastructure that
means what are the ways that a bad guy
for just to use very general terms could
control some segments of
society or a nation-state or something
like that using information and in
particular the digital information
ecosystem now that's the very big
picture you can narrow it down a little
bit and say well instead of focusing
only on the really big picture which
people are starting I think right now
given recent events since 2016 many
Western countries are very very
interested in everything that I just
said but one of the ways that we're
trying to get out ahead of the curve is
that control is not just a matter of
militaries and nations and war there's
any number of reasons why anyone has
things they want to control you know
Pepsi wants to control more of cokes
market Cisco wants to control more of
hallways market and vice versa so you
have especially when in this case it's
no longer a physical tank or bullets or
soldiers that need to go in in this
board game of risk but rather it's just
something as simple as sending these
digitally into the information sphere of
that location and in hacking the
psychology internally of right yeah so
private companies have always wanted to
control more of their space but it's
pretty rare for private companies to use
what the military refers to as kinetic
activities to increase market share the
only example I really know of was
William Randolph Hearst blowing up a
ship to create news and sell more
newspapers that's kind of an outlier you
only see that sort of thing happening
very much but what you do see is
companies using every imaginable kind of
propaganda to build up their markets and
in some cases to attack their
competitors and given what we're seeing
now with just how extreme and how
powerful and how devious the modern
techniques of digitally enhanced
propaganda and psychological
manipulation on a mass scale it would be
very naive to think that private also
the fact that none of it's illegal it's
all completely legal so it would be very
naive to think that private entities and
even mainstream respective
corporations wouldn't try to use these
techniques against each other and we in
fact have already seen a little bit of
this my words are too weighty we good
this is great yeah no this is perfect I
think you got it just right here yeah
you all this talk about democracy and
suffering and wartime and nation states
that would weigh down any microphone
okay so yeah so the private sector is
gonna have to start caring about this
stuff and I think that for the most part
well-informed thoughtful people in
America and a lot of Western countries
are thinking about social networks and
Twitter BOTS and election manipulation
and hacking and blah blah blah that
whole world but there's only a few
people that have taken it a few steps
out and said anybody can do this to
anybody for any reason
anything you want to control any market
you want to dominate this is gonna
happen like crazy I'm kind of hoping
you're gonna ask me for examples please
give us give us those examples so the
the bad example is that a few years ago
it was it came out that Huawei was
putting in backdoors in their
communications equipment and the only
real global scale competitor for hallway
is Cisco so one of the things that the
hallway CEO did at a press conference
when this came out as he said well Cisco
just has back doors for the NSA so who
cares you know it's just six of one half
dozen of the other and and that was it
he had a press conference he said a
thing which I know not everyone's gonna
believe me
but I will tell you that that was
misinformation Cisco does not in fact
voluntarily give backdoors to the NSA
but more importantly Cisco is not
legally required by the government to
give backdoors to the government which
is not the case in other countries so
there was a misinformation statement but
not a campaign now imagine if think
about everything with you know Twitter
bots and memes and conspiracy theories
and queuing on and pizza gate and you
know the whole nine yards like
everything that you're familiar from
from this other world imagine what had
happened if hallway had decided to pull
out all the stops and she use all those
techniques I mean do you think there
would be anything left of Cisco I mean
people would believe that before you
know it they would have massive
fractions of the population believing
that you know the Cisco CEO was part of
it
I don't know I didn't want to give
anybody any ideas but you'd have people
showing up with guns at the cisco
headquarters so that's one example now
the places where you are seeing these
techniques used I think some of the most
like the place where this has already
reached saturation is with crypto scams
because if you go online you're gonna
get an email from Elon Musk or somebody
you know here have some free aetherium
or whatever and some of them were more
elaborate than others you know there's
like a whole like people start to
believe that some guy was hit by a bus
and again I don't wanna go into too many
details because I don't get people
started again but you see a lot of this
going on in the crypto scam world where
people are just you know it's just this
market that isn't really regulated or
controlled in any way and you can make
an enormous amount of money if you can
predictably move public sentiment even
just a few notches on the dial mm-hmm so
these are the kinds of things we're
talking about you know the the the
extreme scenarios haven't really showed
up yet in the private sector but the
extreme scenarios have showed up in you
know the sort of electoral slash
political sector and none of it was
illegal when they did it for politics
so do the math these examples you list
and the potential results the effects of
misinformation have a massive sway on
the way that our world evolves and it's
it's it really sits deep in in the heart
of what what is going on let's start
with at the root level where do you
think even this urge for propagating
misinformation comes from well again
there's this distinction I'm not gonna
call it wartime and peacetime I'm going
to say there's things that just happen
and then there are things that are done
maliciously one of the first several
years ago when I was first getting into
this field I went to a workshop and
someone who was a journalism researcher
gave a presentation about fake news you
know remember the word fake news we used
to say fake news but now nobody says
that anymore
for reasons it was the journalism
researcher was talking about fake news
and they had done surveys in different
countries and like gathered examples of
like things that catch on and get
repeated over and over again you've
probably seen a picture of a flooded
freeway and then there's a shark in the
flooded freeway every time there's a
hurricane or something that somebody
circulates a picture like oh my god the
situation in Houston or Puerto Rico or
New York or whatever is so bad there's a
shark on the freeway and then one of the
reasons that I have a personal
connection to that example is that I
fell for it I forwarded it to my friends
and then another misinformation research
was like yeah I'm doing a study on this
oh no anyway so mulisch thats just plain
old fake news and then there's malicious
fake news which is okay I am trying to
knock down
this candidate or this competitor or
whatever so I'm circulating stories for
a reason so the I think for you know
from a sort of academic point of view
the non malicious stuff is a lot more
interesting because then you know that's
really just studying psychology and
sociology and like what kinds of stories
do people find inherently rewarding or
believable you know is it like a
heartwarming story is it cute does it
make them angry you know there's these
emotional responses and then people tend
to do it and some things just have the
right kind of characteristics to go
viral and people do it because like
conversely the things that are viral are
the things where it's more likely that
when I see it they'll trigger some
combination of emotions that make me
want to forward it so I might just be
forwarding it because you know oh my god
that blows my mind that there's a shark
everybody has to know about this
the hostile side of things is a
different story because you know the
answer to why people would spread
misinformation maliciously is to control
the beliefs of some group of people and
when I say control the beliefs of some
group of people I don't mean you know
like a James Bond mind control ray that
turns you into a zombie what I mean is
that whether you're talking you know
market competition or elections or
whatever for the most part the big you
know the big changes hinge on maybe two
to five percent of any given population
you know if you like if you're a company
and you're looking at your market and
then you imagine 5% of the people in
your market changing to some other
perspective you really have to care
about that I mean the number is that
companies live and die on and their
quarterly reports are a lot less than
two to five percent of their entire user
base or customer base or whatever so
when I say mind control ray what I mean
is a elections getting swayed by oh so
well not yet obviously yeah it's a it's
a stochastic mind control ray
which by which I mean it doesn't pick an
exact person to control but you can say
I can control a small percentage of the
people in the population that I target
and that's enough to accomplish some of
these goals and you know as soon as
different hostile or in some cases just
plain old PR people realize that then
it's open season I mean if you to put it
another way with this mind control ray I
was thinking about I think people who
are kind of familiar with internet
advertising and mass marketing and stuff
like that are familiar with ideas like
click-through rates and conversions and
stuff like that so a conversion rate in
general people are probably thinking you
expect conversion rates of like 0.1% or
whatever and if I told you this Bond
villain has a mind control ray that
works point 1 percent of the time no
one's particularly that's not gonna you
know get a big reaction but you got to
put that together with the two factors
one of them is that as soon as it starts
to reach 2% or 5% that may not sound
scary it might still sound like good
odds and you feel I'm not worried about
that but that's still enough to be a
useful weapon and the other thing is I
mean I got a marketing thing from an
email marketing I don't even remember
but basically they went through in great
detail and seriously this was for
progressive political causes it was like
are you a progressive charity do you
want to send out email campaigns and
gather donations for your progressive
causes and in this whole thing they like
had this dude I had this whole article
about all their methodology and exactly
what they did in the iterative a/b
testing and all this kind of stuff and
basically they're like here's our
results and they're getting 56 %
conversion rates with their campaigns
you know yeah and then at our pre
targeted demographic so not just 50% of
everyone randomly but if you target a
demographic and then you really do all
the work at the cutting edge there may
be an upper bound of like around 50% and
I think I you know if some bad guy had a
50% mind control ray that would turn me
into a zombie
those are not odds I would want to take
let's let's address this also from a
perspective that Ori and I have been
spending a lot of time talking about the
new world and talking about what are the
routes
what are the root causes of some of the
old systems that exist in our world and
then why are some of the incumbents
behind the propagation of those old
systems why are some of the new systems
being held back from their development
and as new systems evolve how can we
make it so that they create the impact
of the decentralization of the
consciousness flowering happening around
the planet how can we get that to happen
most effectively in building the new
world and so when we talk about roots of
the reason why disinformation happens we
look deeper and deeper and deeper and it
seems like it comes from some sort of a
disconnection a disconnection from each
other a disconnection from nature from
source from spirit from God from
creation that it plays its role that
there is there's this role that it plays
in our world where we're rising up to
this challenge to figure out how to
tackle misinformation how to figure out
misinformation security so that way we
can figure out how to at the deepest
level rise to these challenges solve
them learn how to love learn how to not
have these issues with with propagating
malevolence and so that is in my
thinking at a root also at a critical
thinking level when we see a piece of
content for us to be vigilant and and
think deeper about this meme that we're
observing and what is the purpose what
is the purpose that it's serving how can
I go and look deeper into this to know
if what I'm looking at is in fact
something that is real and something
that is something that I can be a deeper
critical thinker about and then
hopefully inspire other
people to be deeper critical thinkers
about so then some of the solutions for
that [ __ ] sex working on let's go
through some of those for misinformation
security wow that was a lot of material
right there on some of the other stuff
things you just got into like it hit on
some other stuff
well the historical part is interesting
and it's on my mind because I just
helped my co-founder Grug just published
an article it's propaganda where he's
talking a little bit about the history
of propaganda and you know what he is
and isn't different now thanks to the
Internet but that's a such a huge topic
on its own yes I think I think I want to
focus in on you sort of the final part
of your question because you're asking
about what could we do differently to
build how could we build our digital
infrastructure or digital information
infrastructure differently to support
better goals so first of all I got to
make a bit of a disclaimer you know I'm
I'm starting a company to do a specific
thing that makes money which I believe
will help contribute towards that in
some small way but I can't really say
that as an entrepreneur I'm trying to
solve all the world's problems of course
I think that do you you know based on
you know from my experience working in
the social media industry I think that
it's almost embarrassing I'm like the
millionth person to say this but the
extractive attention economy and the
engagement driven business models that
drive all these companies we're really
going to have to do something about that
huge problem we were going we have you
as one of the guests we were inviting
you to be our guest on that social media
in the attention economy panel that we
did last year yeah that was one of the
best if you guys haven't seen that one
check out that video on our channel
social media and the attention economy
it's such a good conversation on that
exact subject yeah and I I mean I really
regretted not being there but it's one
of these things you know my cup
over where it's like oh do I go to the
extractive attention economy panel where
do I go to this you know Special
Operations Command or you know different
people need to hear different things so
anyway yeah so many people talk about
that and but you know true stone Harris
this is a great guy who I've met a few
times I think he has a lot of good
things to say about that and is kind of
leading the conversation in a good way
yeah I don't need to rest is also great
there yeah well and Alex Thomas of
course also has this sorry I just got to
take a moment of humility here I'm not
gonna say also anything alex has an
enormous amount of experience and I have
a little bit of experience and Alex has
very very good ideas that have been very
inspirational to me about how the
structure of these companies in these
platforms could be tweaked to generate
better outcomes and that's that's the
kind of conversation we need to be
happening we need to have people who
know how it works now and have good
intentions for how it should work in the
future this whole stuff about I mean I
probably shouldn't even go there but
when people just start waving things
around like we need to break up the
companies or whatever it's like that
that's too blunt of a club like you know
you smash the company into little pieces
and then later something else is going
on and like precisely how does that
actually solve the problem I mean you
know maybe breaking up the company does
need to be a part of a solution but like
somebody's gonna have to explain why
that would actually change something
which of course then it doesn't make a
good political slogan or whatever I
would say that for so my experience was
at Twitter I worked at Twitter for a
while and I thought a lot about these
questions while I was there and I went
to great lengths to try to have
conversations with as many people as I
could and one of the things that I think
is that we need we need to look for we
need to look for solutions that the
companies aren't going to throw their
entire resources into fighting against
because if you if the only plan you have
is to break up Facebook
Facebook has a lot of money to spend on
lawyers and PR firms and stuff like that
and they're not gonna go willingly with
that you know you're setting it up for a
fight but if you ask a question if you
start looking at things like well here's
this you know here's a small incremental
change that moves things a little bit in
the right direction or more importantly
here's a new market that could open up
for this company that would give them a
new revenue stream which would create a
new set of incentives and then it would
actually be a management priority to
start doing some of these things that
what I see is that every business is the
same you know you have some things that
contribute to the bottom line and then
you have some things that contribute to
the PR that you need to generate because
of current events and the latter things
are putting on a show and then later
something else will be the PR cycle and
you're not gonna change your
fundamentals there but if you make more
money because X happens then that will X
will continue to be a priority for the
company so the problem is that right now
actually if you go back historically
there was this era of web 2.0 you know
web 1.0 was just like the web pages with
like the HTML blank tag and you know
funky old stuff that you can see at the
Internet Archive if you go and visit and
then people were like web 2.0 which is
like interactive web apps so now it's
like a platform or a product as opposed
to just like a banner in some sense a
sign and then they were like well okay
it's a product so how does the product
make money and I don't know if there was
a really good reason for this or not but
in any case it really feels like just an
accident of history now that everybody
kind of jumped on this bandwagon of
we're just going to put ads on
everything and that's how everyone's
gonna make money and do it now the only
business that anyone has is actually
advertising so there's been a lot of
problems there's been a lot of problems
based on that yes but the important
thing I think is to go back and to say
it doesn't have to be this way nobody
built the system that way because that
was the only way that would work now the
problem is that each individual system
there's going to be a different answer
for what a better
revenue model is so for instance you
know if you have like tinder tinder
makes money by showing ads but like the
individual user of tinder there's
definitely a value proposition that they
really want
so maybe the solution is that that one
should be charging the end user but if
you look at Twitter you're in a really
tricky situation because everything
about like the very essence of Twitter
is that it is fast if you have something
that you want to say to the Internet
Twitter is the fastest way to do that
like if there's an earthquake people
will tweet oh my god there's an
earthquake and then take cover
and if it you know if it took four extra
seconds to send out a tweet then people
wouldn't do that and then there would be
a niche for someone else to build a
product where you could say something
without that four extra seconds delay so
that puts you in a very challenging
situation also nobody's gonna pay for a
subscription to be able to you know once
in a lifetime say oh my god there's an
earthquake do you know there's not a lot
of overhead with some of these pure
social products so you like people
wonder about I wonder about I wonder
about it
so David one of the things that you're
talking about here is the way that we
migrate away from the extract of
attention at ome and towards the new
enabling new combinatorics to show up of
the waste that we can sustain things
like these projects like a youtube
channel that is not necessarily based on
watch these videos as long as possible
but rather how do we maybe get viewers
and patrons and donations and stuff yes
just so there's so there's stuff like
that and then that's one thing is fixing
the extract of attention I mean fixing
the business plan it's a great challenge
but then there's also how do you prevent
ask coccyx how do you guys prevent these
mass psychological misinformation
attacks so I see what you're getting at
so I'm gonna yeah
dial it back from this you know real big
picture let's reform society kind of
stuff and talk about the part the little
part of the problem the work harvan off
to work on here is right now if somebody
uses these techniques like I was
describing earlier when I gave the
example of you know what if Huawei had
decided to go all-out against Disko yeah
how could that have really played out so
if somebody does decide to go out all
out nobody knows what to do
we're just at the point now where people
can recognize that it's happening which
is good so for instance if you go back
to around 1992 no one there was no such
thing as cybersecurity the like there
was this brand new thing called the
Internet and then there was this big
internet worm and it took down a bunch
of systems and people are like what just
happened and then over the next few
years there were more and more bad
things that happened that were
attributed to the actions of
identifiable individuals and then people
started to realize okay there's a
security thing going on here but they
still didn't really have you know I mean
I kind of sometimes I jokingly say that
the early days of cyber security were a
bunch of you know kids in the basement
and when cybersecurity became a thing
basically the FBI came and arrested half
of them and hired the other half okay
like that was the best we could do it's
like I don't know some of these guys
let's just try to get them to help stop
the problem and some of the rest of
these guys we're just gonna I don't know
try to make an example of them with
little rhyme or reason and that's kind
of the arrow we're in right now except
no one's getting arrested
what we need there what we need is we
need a response model and I really want
to give away too much of our secret
sauce as well as you can I'll give away
as much as I can as an example as with
any security you do have to start with a
sort of preventive thing like you know
like if you call a security company
after your house has been robbed there
isn't that much they can do but you call
you know you call the security company
and they'll come in and they'll do a
review they'll do a threat assessment so
in this case since we're talking about
cognitive threats the threat assessment
is going to be understanding what the
value propositions for your business are
and then finding in what
changes in public sentiment could hurt
your business's value propositions and
then what are narratives which if they
went viral would lead to those changes
and then what are what are the factors
that would be necessary to trigger those
narratives and how do we prevent that
from happening so for instance one
example that like an obvious example you
have somebody is a CEO of a company and
you do an assessment and then you say
okay so one bad thing that might happen
to this company is that you know the
rumor monger people on 4chan and so
forth might find a bunch of you know
memes or Photoshop photos or real photos
or whatever you know that show you know
like somebody making grabby hands or
something like that and then they
propagate this and they construct this
whole narrative that they're you know
like some sexual impropriety or
misbehavior or something like that and
then they just pound it and pound it and
pound it and then everybody's talking
about how this politician or the CEO or
whatever that's the only thing anybody's
thinking about with that person and then
that is a disaster for that brand yeah
so the kinds of ways that you work with
that and this is one of the things I
called misinformation Aikido you really
can't you can't stop it head-on it's too
powerful and that's not how cognition
works it's like telling people don't
think of an elephant
you can't stop ideas but you're thinking
of an elephant now because I said don't
think of an elephant and if we just sit
here and stare at each other in awkward
silence you're gonna be seeing they're
thinking of an elephant but if I give
you something to do or how beautiful you
are yeah or that looking deep into each
other yes yeah have you ever done the
diad meditation anyway that's another
another topic so if I distract you if I
give you something else that will make
the elephant irrelevant or if I had a
chance to plan ahead
you know if we hung out every day and
every day I'd be like hi the elephant
thing it's the elephant thing you'd be
so sick of me talking about this stupid
elephant that like you just wouldn't
even listen anymore
you couldn't carry mmm so for instance
if you've identified that there's a
really critical vulnerability in the you
know in the in narrative security I
would even say for this company which is
that we know that there's a pretty good
chance that some pictures might surface
from that CEO just as a side note here I
suppose at that point then I have to ask
a question well actually are they really
bad if somebody's really bad then I'm
gonna have to ask the question well do
we really want their business and
fortunately we haven't encountered a
situation like that yet but I just want
you to know I'm thinking about it but
anyway if there's somebody that we think
is basically ok but you know if you dig
deep enough and anybody's past you're
gonna find something from when they were
in college or whatever that's not so
great and this person knows somebody I
oh god I wish I could say somebody I
know at another company has some
pictures that they've really tried to
get rid of because it would be so bad
and it was just a cardboard cutout but
still people would not think it was
funny if it came out right now so what
you might do in a situation like that is
you say okay here's the thing that we're
afraid of people thinking so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna make a bunch of
crappy versions of that and we're gonna
just spew them all over the internet
we're gonna make bad low-grade Photoshop
pictures of you know we're gonna put the
CEOs face on this other meme that's
already popular and we're gonna put it
on this other meme that's already
popular we're gonna do this and then
we're gonna just like post them
everywhere and you know like I mean if
they want to pay for it you can even
like do some traditional PR and make a
joke about it just make a joke about the
whole thing and then everybody's so sick
of the idea of compromising pictures of
the CEO back when he was in college that
if the real ones ever come out nobody
cares anymore so that's the kind of
thing that you can do and actually I
just read Neal Stephenson's latest book
fall or dodge in hell and I was kind of
shocked because in around chapter 11 I'm
going to
the book and I'm like oh my god he
describes our whole business model right
here he's way again way ahead of the
game
and then in the acknowledgments he's
like I learned this from this person at
this conference I'm like oh my
co-founders are at that conference right
now and I don't know this person but I'm
one step away from the like everyone in
my group is one step away from the
person that the idea came from so it's
kind of an again
small world and that's also interesting
that you guys are all around the
solutions around misinformation security
let me see if there's a good way to to
listen to hit this tennis ball back so
all of the potential creative
possibilities that information could
come in and target a given psychographic
and demographic of populations if
there's a way that a company can cast
another malevolent misinformation
campaign against another company it's
it's in a sense preparing for the these
malevolent misinformation attacks on
other companies on psychographic and
demographic pockets of people in
countries and so you know what
narratives are the potentials that are
going to come ahead of time you're
prepared to cognitively be be jujitsu
Aikido to is this brand Walton calls it
misinformation jujitsu so you're
prepared for these styles of
misinformation for the for the
narratives the the target demographic is
predict target demographics for Pia
whether it be the CEO of a company or
the general populace of a democracy it
does these some of these techniques work
better in a targeted fashion if you're
talking about like the entire population
of a democracy it's kind of like there's
so many ways like if it's just the
just for example you have a democracy
there's only say there's only two
political parties just pick a
hypothetical example you have this
incredibly broad problem of like getting
slightly more than 50% of the people to
prefer one over the other you can
literally use any narrative to make that
happen and the resources that would go
into that would be so enormous then
you're talking about you know an ongoing
monitoring and protection campaign that
I can't even begin to start talking
about techniques at that level but what
I do think is important and the reason
why I believe that doing this in the
private sector is one of the key
elements of really solving the
big-picture problem is that if we do
this one piece at a time that each piece
we do now that's just a tool in the
toolbox that's ready to go and if
there's a toolbox ready to go to fight
back against misinformation and to make
it ineffective attackers aren't going to
use an attack that's well defended
attackers are choosing to use this
attack against us because we're
completely helpless and undefended so of
course they're gonna use this attack but
if there's a big infrastructure and
everybody's ready for it you know like
France in 2018 there were Russian
attacks on the French election and they
were ready and they had like armies of
people on the internet like
counteracting things as they came up and
if that happens enough times then
they're gonna they're gonna figure out
that they should leave France alone
because they know it's well defended so
you know it's just like if you get an
alarm system for your house or to say
something somebody once said to me yeah
I heard that the important thing is that
you just need a bike lock that's a
little bit bigger than the one on the
bike next to yours
so security is always an arms race
there's no such thing as perfect
security but you have a situation where
you increase the cost to the attacker of
a particular modality then the freed the
likelihood of that attack taking place
becomes much lower I like that and I
also
like the focus on the spiritual
awakening and development of people
around the world the more that we also
focus on that the less these malevolent
attacks go out in the first place the
more we create a world of abundance
whenever we talk about things like the
importance of of of quantum computers
being able to break cryptography and and
just things like this I'm always
thinking about yes and and just like
this with misinformation you make
helping people become more critically
thinking about all of the ways that
people could cast malevolent attacks in
AI think about also yes and the
spiritual awakening and flowering that
can happen consciously around our world
towards abundance towards maximizing
prosperity and away from fear a way of
healing the trauma towards growth and
how that itself acts as a massive
solution to decrease malevolence and to
increase prosperity so yeah I do I see
those both happening and the importance
of those both at the well yeah and
actually let me make that a little bit
more explicit even what I personally my
journey after 2016 I had already been
doing spiritually related things and
focusing on health and well-being and in
particular mindfulness and mental
well-being and the training of attention
and all these sorts of things and long
story short I realized that these kinds
of spiritual awakening and well-being
and you know kindness and compassion and
people doing the self-knowledge and
stuff like that that doesn't happen very
well in a totalitarian dictatorship it
doesn't happen very well in Handmaid's
Tale world doesn't happen very well in
you know pick any you know country with
some tin-pot dictator where people just
get disappeared in the middle of the
night which happens I mean I had a
friend at a place that I worked who was
really struggling with being able to
talk back to their managers when they
thought they were doing something wrong
at some point she was from another
country it's
quite a stir when you were a kid did
people just like get thrown into sacks
and disappeared is that kind of the way
you're used to thinking of Authority and
her responses oh well you know by the
time I was a kid it didn't happen very
much anymore which is like think of the
psychological impact of that I mean
either you know you're not gonna really
enjoy your meditation retreat if that is
the environment you're living in unless
you're a particular CEO visiting Mayan
market that is a whole other story so
for me I kind of took a step back and
was like whoa we're gonna lose we're
gonna lose the playing field in which
this higher development could even have
a potential of taking place if we don't
take a step back and fix some of the
leaks in the foundation so for me it's
like all right I got to fix some of the
leaks in the foundation before I can
really go back to working on widely
propagating mindfulness and you know in
any way Richie my old advisor he's doing
a great job of getting people on board
with mindfulness there's plenty of other
people working on well-being and things
like that but I do see exactly as you
said it's all definitely a continuum for
me and it was all part of the same
calculation for me of where I want to
put my efforts for that goal I love that
and let's play on that a little bit more
you focus so much of your time doing
your PhD in psychology neuroscience in
Madison in Wisconsin you spent a lot of
time with the center for healthy minds
and focusing on meditation science teach
us about what is the importance of
bringing together science and
spirituality together as we study
meditation and what that does as we can
help bring that to more people around
the world
oh boy you just you went like one step
forward and then you like hit me from
the other side with this bringing
together science and spirituality that's
an some heady big-picture stuff and god
I feel like we could just start at the
beginning a whole other hour to talk
about you will with Orion of yeah but
just to narrow it down a little bit I
would say that like I started to say a
minute ago this idea of helping people
you know bring the idea of mindfulness
to greater
hmm you know greater public awareness I
I'm trying to make it not sound like a
marketing thing or something like that
because sometimes it does come off like
that it's like you know as soon as you
start to tell people oh you know people
should you know you we should like there
should be more compassion people should
practice kindness and stuff like that
and then before you know it it's an ad
campaign and people are like wearing
that you know the silicone bracelets or
whatever and then people are just buying
into an identity without actually doing
anything and that's the real trick when
you're talking about these big picture a
psycho cognitive or spiritual or
whatever if you're thinking these are
virtues I guess that's another way of
putting it that's very traditional if
you're talking virtue ethics and you're
saying well we would like to cultivate
more virtues on a wider scale you're
that you're telling I mean what you're
saying is you want people to change who
they are you want people to change the
essence of who they are because you want
them to think and behave differently and
that is the essence of who they are so I
got to heady for myself even there what
I was focusing on was mindfulness and
what a lot of people focus on is
mindfulness and like you said it was 10
years of my life is very hard for me to
narrow it down to a quick summary but
what I would say is that one one version
of this is that making an exercise where
like a deliberate exercise of
strengthening certain capabilities of
your mind namely attentional control and
stability yeah is a tool that you can
then use to do all the other things that
you would want to do psychologically so
it's just like saying you know if
somebody has some sort of physical
problem you know like maybe you have
sciatica or like maybe your knees are
bad or something like that there's a
general sense that like if you don't
know anything about exercise it's gonna
be really hard to address that so you
kind of need a general purpose
foundation of physical movement
knowledge and experience
before you can target something like oh
I'm gonna try to do physical therapy on
my knee unless you can afford to just
have somebody do it for you like a
physical therapist or everybody goes to
see a therapist and the therapist tells
them what they should think but you'd be
nice for people to be a little bit more
independent and self-sufficient and so
long story short a lot of us have
focused on mindfulness as a good way of
talking about the general purpose skill
that gives you foundation for all the
kinds of things you might want to do
like cultivating compassion or whatever
and I think you do I just I should make
a nod to the fact that you do see a lot
of talk about this in Silicon Valley and
the entrepreneur community and stuff
like that people are really interested
in these sorts of things because as an
entrepreneur starting a company as we
both know and presumably a lot of our
audience are kind of on the same sort of
world there are a lot of things you have
to do that are actually kind of
emotionally hard you know like you have
to keep the faith even through long
periods of hopelessness where nothing's
happening and you have to be patient you
know you sometimes you have to be
charismatic sometimes you have to be
humble sometimes you have to watch
people's emotional reactions very
carefully that's because you got to see
if your pitch is going wrong so there's
all these mental skills that you need to
learn and then if you have a sort of
general foundation of okay I'm good at
working with my mind and that can give
you a basis to do all these other things
yeah that's so good yeah if when when we
drill into the deepest practices of our
own psyche and our habits and knowing
ourselves it
it begins flowering in all aspects of
the way that we engage with our world
yeah and I I love that so much and it
actually the deeper practices that we
have with our non-separation our
interconnectedness with everything the
more that we also then
partake in building that new world that
our hearts all know as possible yes oh
that's I'm happy that we did that bit
and okay I want to do a couple on rapid
fire
okay okay rapid fire yeah towards this
end so um first part is the the your
thoughts on the involvement of
decentralization technologies in the
building of the new free speech of the
way that we disseminate information to
each other
what is that optimal fabric for the
dissemination are you asking nation what
is the optimal fabric are you asking if
I think blockchain is a solution they're
both because is how much is that a role
in that optimal and what is that optimal
yeah so there are a few so one
definition of blockchain technologies is
it is a slow immutable database and the
idea of an immutable database like in
the globally immutable like nobody can
just decide that they're gonna go in and
change an entry there are potentially a
lot of applications for that the scope
of applications is limited by how slow
and resource intensive is right now I
think we all know what happened to all
the people historically who said oh that
takes too much computational power it's
impossible which is it later we have
enough computational power I also think
that people are probably going to find
ways to make faster more optimized
things on the more fundamental level the
problem is that like a brick is
immutable like if a majority votes that
it's not a break it's still a brick but
the way blockchain works is actually
that if the majority of nodes or
whatever you want to call it if any any
distributed larger any distributed
system the majority of participants
decide to change it it's baked into the
system that it really is majority rule
so there are plenty of applications for
which that's fine and then there are
plenty of other applications for which
it's fine and tell some
doomsday scenarios that you never
thought possible actually turn out to be
possible there's this is this is an it's
an existential question about this
technology because they're like there's
only two ways of deciding what reality
is and one of them is that you refer to
something physical that doesn't go away
and the other one is majority rule
there's no there's no there's no other
way to do it I mean it's because I mean
digital information by its nature can be
changed and edited and stuff like that
so you can just distribute it widely
enough that you can ever find all the
copies and change it you can put on
paper and put it in a vault and then
that you've turned it into a physical
instantiation that is immutable by
virtue of being physical but somebody
could still steal it anyway so there's
some issues that need to be sorted out
and I think that they're absolutely
worth sorting out because the idea of
having the idea of the distributed
ledger where you can have things that
can't just be changed by anyone who
wants to change them is really important
because I don't know if people
understand how bad the situation with
misinformation is right now but again
the Neal Stephenson book that I just
read is projecting very slightly out
into the future and imagining a scenario
where somebody does a misinformation
campaign and then 10 years down the road
people believe that the city isn't there
that actually is there and they're like
arguing back and forth I mean you could
go and look the physical city is there
so having on the digital side something
to anchor something so that it can't
just be changed later can solve one set
of problems that go with one piece of
the puzzle I don't think it's like a
panacea for anything but it's definitely
a tool that we didn't have before that
we do have now that's really useful okay
sorry I wasn't really good fire thank
you for insight and then the other one
is the optimal design of that social
fabric that enables the communication
one of the things is inclusive stake
holding that we've been diving deeper
into that is very interesting when I
actually have an inclusive stake in your
fitness then I don't spread a meme of
malevolence I don't spread a meme of
self dealing to myself
I think that the there are a lot of
things that you can talk about in terms
of the architecture of social networks
and I'm gonna say that if you really
want to see a lot of good insights on
that just follow Alec's famous on
Twitter because he has a lot of the best
things to say that are really well
informed excellent and then there are a
lot of things having to do with changing
the revenue model yes turning into
earlier you know phrase like Twitter
right now doesn't make more money by
having good quality information on it
than they do by having bad quality
information on it but if they did then
things would change if posts were made
and ranked based on the amount of
educational content that was in them or
knowledge that was in them work
assistance that was in them stuff like
that versus just whatever it is but I
think a more important question comes
from the fact that this isn't the real
question you're asking can't be answered
on the network architecture level
because I think posting this again this
is like starting a whole other
conversation but I'll just give you a
teaser here maybe we can talk again
about this sometime if you want to
attack a society with an information
attack and you know cause discord and
problems turning people against each
other's one of the things that's one of
the weapons in the arsenal yeah and the
way that you turn people against each
other is you find the existing cracks
and you widen them so if you have a
society where everybody feels like they
have some sort of shared you know what's
the word enfranchisement in the society
then it's a lot harder to attack that
with these sorts of attacks so the way
that I say that like what one of my you
know like many side goals and doing this
is to get in front of as many military
and national security audience as I can
and say social and economic justice is a
national security problem because if our
society is fractured
then hostile foreign powers can use that
against us yeah yeah okay and the other
ones on rapid-fire are do you think that
Humanity is a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence this is the
this is the new the new hot version of
are we living in a simulation thanks to
who is it that raise it that way musk
for yeah that way oh god you you have
you only ask big questions don't you I
think that personally I think that it is
very compelling philosophically that
there are more than one different some
things planes of existence or dimensions
or parallel universes or whatever or you
know there's just so many different ways
of talking about that I think
historically you see in some but not all
religions this idea that this reality is
like the dream of a larger mind or
something like that and if you imagine
that what if you imagine that whatever
it is that would be quote unquote
simulating us is obviously so powerful
as to be more or less beyond our
understanding at that point it kind of
doesn't matter whether you call it oh
it's the mind of Brahma dreaming us into
existence or it's a big computer
simulating us or something like that so
you know yes and no I think if people
are going to try to say that they know
what the nature of that is I think
anyone who claims to have evidence for a
specific version of that is really
overreaching but I think even just
thinking of the vastness of the idea of
a multiverse or there's a lot of value
in that
yes yes a it opens us up to some of the
more abstract bigger picture ways of
going beyond even what's going on here
on our planet and what is the ultimate
nature of this reality it's such a
crucial topic okay the other two what
has been your most profound experience
in creation do I get to tell stories
he'll be a quick of course course he'll
sort so the first time I ever had a
psychedelic experience we did a pretty
low dose of mushrooms long story short
we walked through the Arboretum in
Seattle and I was looking for a mango
because I asked my friend what do you do
when you're tripping I saw you eat some
fruit it'll be really nice what kind of
fruit how about a mango so we walked
through this long walk and then we're at
the grocery store I'm looking for a
mango and I can't find a mango so I have
an orange and then we're not really
tripping anymore and we have this super
long walk back home in the dark through
the forest so we're walking along the
road through the Arboretum I'm walking
along and a car drives by and something
comes flying out the window and lands on
the grass in front of me and it's a
mango what so I'm looking at the mango
and like hey guys look at this
and it was just like huh that's weird
and at that point in my life where I was
at in my development I was just like huh
that's weird and I just went on so about
five years ago I was actually telling
this story to a friend of mine as we
were walking along a trail through a
forest in Madison where I was and
literally while I'm telling him the
story then I get to the conclusion about
yeah and I didn't eat the mango I feel
like that's kind of a regret that I
didn't like accept the gift from the
universe or the lesson like I wasn't
ready to receive whatever the wisdom or
the whatever from the universe because I
didn't think to pick it up and and take
it and while I'm saying this we both
looking and by the side of the road
there's a tree where three branches come
out and it makes a little tripod like
that uh-huh and in the middle of the
tripod is a completely peeled orange
that's fresh it's soo we're walking by
and we're looking at that and I get
about 20 paces for the long and I'm like
yeah I should have eaten the mango and
suddenly I just stopped mm-hmm
but I'm like wait a second so I run back
and I get the orange and then we eat the
orange and it was great
it's always interesting thinking about
when the experience first happens to
your reaction and then several years
down the line how you feel about that
those experiences yeah okay and then
what has been your what do you find is
the most beautiful thing in creation I
could say all of it or something I don't
know that's a tough one
my mind is going in circles yeah I think
I'm gonna I'm just I'm gonna pass on
that one for now you said all of it we'd
like that yeah we've had that answer on
we like that one that's a good one yeah
it's so beautiful Wow whoo Dave thank
you so much yeah information security
Wow thank you for enlightening us you
are very welcome thank you for coming on
the show greatly appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you thank you out thanks
you thank you thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations with your friends families
congresspeople online about
misinformation security about the topics
that we covered in the show about how to
early detect and attribute these
disinformation campaigns how to set up
this jiu-jitsu or Aikido for the for the
Prevention of the misinformation and
also do check out the links in the bio
below to cog SEC dot tech that's e OG
SEC Tech also David's LinkedIn profile
also the coccyx Twitter profile check
those out and also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the leaders the
organizations in your communities that
you believe in spiritual there support
them help them grow help them flourish
you can find all of our links to our
show below thank you or Shapira for
co-producing big love
to you brother thank you and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon and I want to thank
everybody that supported me and hi mom
hi dad I love it bye everyone please